foreign
[Music]
does this one work yeah this one works
okay awesome uh so hi everyone my name
is Keaton Ellis
um this uh the work that I'm going to be
presenting to you guys is joint with
Shahar karif who is in the econ
department and my advisor Eric is by at
the University of Maryland where I come
from and I think unlike most people in
this room I am an economics PhD and I
definitely come from a very different
space but hopefully there's some things
that you'll find interesting about this
talk I'm an experimental Economist which
means in particular that unfortunately I
have to deal with humans
um
so I don't have theoretical guarantees
in the exact same way because even if I
uh prove some economic uh pruesome
theorem about a theory model
um
it may not actually work on the people
that I'm trying to analyze so in
particular with uh with economics uh you
know economic theory in particular is
this very sort of strong tie to
experimental economics in the sense that
um you know you can construct a theory
you can say it it's uh you know it's a
model if and only if you have some
actions on choice but then you actually
need to go and see whether or not people
actually choose in that way and that's
where experimental economics comes in
within this there are a bunch of
different ways that people care about
experiments and run experiments on on
people either in the lab in the field
with lots of people with very few people
I focus on lab experiments and in
particular I focus on lab experiments
where I look at a single individual's
decisions uh it may affect other people
but it's a single individual's decisions
uh and generally the common theme in
this type of work is that I have various
decision theoretic models that I've that
I've got and I want to go and
distinguish between them I've got Model
A that someone's proposed I've got model
B that someone's proposed and I want to
distinguish between the by cleverly
constructing experiments such that if I
associate with model A I choose X if I'm
more consistent with model B I choose Y
and so on I've got work in this there
um things that uh that people do in the
space uh plenty but generally this
analysis is done sort of relative to
other economic models so I have you know
two models that I care about uh that
people have made very strong assumptions
about
um
about choice and whether or not these
assumptions are correct are one thing
but one of the things that uh we were
interested in doing in this project uh
in general is sort of taking the concept
of machine learning algorithms where you
know I don't have as many stringent
assumptions about decision making and
it's more or less just some sort of
function approximation to data
um
uh but you know it has very useful out
of sample uh prediction properties uh
which is you know generally not what you
think about when you think about sort of
economic analysis maybe you think about
consistency with some preference or sort
of how I can recover preferences from
data that people have but it's still a
very useful question a useful question
for Applied demand analysis and the
typical approach that you're going to
get
um is something along the lines of I
assume some model I estimate some some
parameters associated with it I have a
demand function that I get from that
model and then I go fit this to some
data that I care about
uh and one of the things that we're
interested in checking is in you know
instead of assuming I have Model A and
model B and try and test these instead
uh you know under what empirical
conditions do our models with very
strong assumptions outperform more
flexible models and in this case we're
just going to use machine learning
models for that
for that um and so in this project We
compare the relative prediction accuracy
and then also the model flexibility of
economic models in particular one that
I'll talk about in a second to machine
learning models and we're going to run
what we think is a fair horse race here
where all models are going to receive
identical input and they're going to be
asked to predict exactly the same thing
um
we're going to be doing this all at the
individual level and so uh we have about
a thousand people in the data set that
I'm going to be talking about we're
going to for each person train a model
and then have it Go predict
um what that specific person is going to
do so we're not including any
information across individuals we don't
have extra information like Choice
response time data or any social
demographic information that would be
feeding into a machine learning model
um
so we're just going to run it in that
way
uh and then the thing that we're going
to be using is a budget line
experimental data which is sort of what
classical microeconomic theory is built
on uh and so we're going to be able to
use these classical revealed preference
techniques in order to analyze our
results
and we're going to be using three
separate Tools in order to try and
analyze uh what we see first is just a
measure of prediction accuracy where
more or less what I do is I scale my uh
I scale my results
um sort of from zero to one where zero
is I have uh you know no uh Benchmark
improvement over oh does this thing work
I have no Benchmark improvement over uh
a random uh Benchmark model that I have
uh and a completeness value of one is
that I'm going to have the best possible
prediction that I can in any specific
environment a similar measure for model
flexibility where I can talk about sort
of how a model can fit any arbitrary
data that I throw at it if I have a
restricting this value of 0 in this case
my model can more or less connect the
dots to any data that I want and if I
have a restrict in this value of one my
model is going to be no more flexible
than a benchmark which again I'm going
to assume is just random uniform choice
and then finally we have a measure of
consistency with Garb in first order
stochastic dominance which are sort of
axioms that underpin utility
maximization
um
and and that's a cardinal value so I can
say sort of whether or not someone is
more consistent with uh with these
axioms and sort of how much more
consistent they are
thank you
so for this experiment we've got 956
subjects and they face a budget line
that looks like this they're going to be
two equally likely states of nature
States one and state two
um and what we've got is uh you know got
for the subjects is uh these X and Y
axes correspond to Aero Securities
associated with each state and so narrow
security is going to pay out in the
state that it's associated with and it
will pay nothing otherwise
um and what we're going to be doing is
just taking this type of uh
taking this type of question where you
know if I make some Choice my x-axis is
going to be how much I get paid out in
state one my y-axis is going to be how
much I get paid out in state two uh I'm
gonna have subjects make a choice on
this and then I'm going to have them do
that 49 more times so I'm going to ask a
subject to um sort of make this decision
where I vary these prices by essentially
varying the slope I can make it flatter
I can make it steeper I can push it out
um and the goal for our models is to
predict uh
just a one-dimensional output along this
line
so uh of course this is going to be a
sort of analysis of machine learning
models versus economic models
relative to some of the applications
that you guys use uh we have very small
model uh very small data sets and in
that sense we're using very simple
regressions tree based models and very
small neural networks in order to do our
prediction on the machine learning side
and we're just going to be pulling
things from uh from the literature uh
that that have used these types of
models before
in terms of the economic model that
we're looking at we're going to be using
uh rank dependent utility which is a
sort of a behavioral economic model that
is an extension of very classical
economic theory or essentially what I
have is
um I've got
additive separability among the two
states and then the state that is uh
sort of giving me a lower payoff I'm
going to be waiting that State uh by
some parameter Alpha
um and if Alpha equals one I'm in a very
special case of expected utility which
is more or less the backbone of most
economic analysis this also satisfies
monotonacy with respect to first order
stochastic dominance
um and like I said earlier we're going
to just assume some utility functions
and more or less we'll have two
parameters based on whichever one of
these I want to use I'll have one
parameter either row or gamma and then
I'll have an alpha parameter that I'm
going to go estimate via data and do out
of sample prediction
and in terms of the initial results that
we're going to be getting
higher completeness values are better in
this case so
when we take a look at our rank
dependent utility model against any of
the other models that we're taking a
look at it's at least as good as sort of
each individual family of models that
we're looking at but it's worse than uh
if I take sort of the X post best model
per subject
um
and when I take a look at the family of
models that we're comparing against
despite the fact that sort of rank
dependent utility and tree based models
have more or less the same completeness
so they have more or less the same
prediction accuracy a rank dependent
utility is going to be more restrictive
which means it's it's less it's less
able to fit any data that's thrown at it
it's it's got stronger assumptions on
what the functional form can be
I've also got results for expected
utility it's more or less exactly the
same as rank dependent utility so that
special case uh doesn't doesn't hinder
out of sample prediction at all and it's
slightly more restrictive
so the the liter the literature on this
generally want if I'm if I'm thinking
about it from sort of driving an
economic theory perspective I want more
completeness because I want a model that
has better out of sample prediction and
then I want more restrictiveness because
I want to model that
um
whose assumptions uh that I'm making on
it are are the correct assumptions uh
that describe Behavior
and so it's sort of lexicographical I
want completeness first and then after
that I want restrictiveness I don't
really care if I'm making you know if I
have very high restrictiveness if the
assumptions that I'm making are not
actually correct
the other thing that we took a look at
here is
instead of just taking a look at uh
subjects on average what we did was we
took subjects and we sort of binned them
by how consistent they were with our our
axioms of uh economic choice and these
are sort of equally sized bins of about
250 subjects each and uh the leftmost
bin constitutes the subjects that are
least consistent with uh with
rationality the ribospin are the
subjects that are most consistent and
then the y-axis here is the proportion
of subjects for whom our model rank
dependent utility is going to be more
complete uh than the various machine
learning models that we're taking a look
at
um and the main thing that we're seeing
here is that as I get more consistent
with our um
are axioms of economic choice of utility
maximization uh the model that uses
these assumptions uh does monotonically
better although there do exist subjects
even at the top for whom machine
learning models that we're analyzing do
better
and this is not necessarily driven by
one model doing the same more or less
across all subjects I'm going to show a
series of
um
Scatter Plots here where instead of
showing the relative performance of one
model over another instead I'm showing
sort of the the completeness value of
each model per subject on the X and Y
axes where if I'm on the 45 degree line
here I'm going to be taking a look I'm
going to be
uh having the exact same predictive
accuracy for that subject regardless of
which model that I used
um this is the first quartile this
lowest consistency with uh
are axioms and most subjects here on the
45 degree line although there are
subjects who are in this sort of uh top
top half of our diagram here where rank
dependent utility does fairly poorly and
machine learning models do fairly well
at predicting them these seem to be
subjects that have systematic violations
of uh of the axioms in a way that are
easily predictable by a machine learning
model otherwise most subjects are along
this 45 degree line within some sort of
band
and as I consider more consistent
quartiles of subjects
um
what I essentially end up getting is
sort of a shift towards this upper right
corner so it's not necessarily that uh
you know machine learning models are
doing bad even on the most consistent
subjects but rather that there's just a
slight nestling underneath this 45
degree line as I move forward
uh so in terms of the
sort of conclusions that we draw from
this
you know at least right now so long as
the assumptions underpinning my economic
models are moderately satisfied in
general the economic model performance
is going to be better
um
hooray I can toot my own horn as The
Economist in the room
um there is a caveat of course which is
that this more or less is probably the
best data environment that you're
possibly going to get for an economic
model in the sense that relative to
other data sets that uh that we have at
least in experimental economics we have
a lot of individual level data per
person there are
no causality concerns because this is an
experiment and things are mostly going
to be explained by risk and or loss
aversion in this environment
um of course the counterfactual that
economists are particularly concerned
about is you know if this is the best
environment and machine learning models
we're doing better than economic models
just sort of straight off the bat uh we
should be very concerned I probably
would not have a job
um
so
um you know the other thing that we're
seeing is that you know the acts the the
measures that we're using to talk about
consistency with our axioms uh tend to
work as I get more uh consistent model
uh more consistent subjects uh with
respect to uh GARP in first order
stochastic dominance according to this
measure our models do better on those
individuals I mean that's that's sort of
a confirmation that
um these these metrics actually do what
they're supposed to do or at least
intuitively they're supposed to do
uh and so the things that we're
interested in looking at is whether or
not sort of you know this is too special
of an environment it's too good for this
all to be true in the sense that we're
going to be taking a look uh and uh at
more complex Choice environments for
subjects either subjects where uh
environments where subjects are asked to
do sort of harder Problems by either
considering more Goods on varying the
probabilities I don't even give them the
probability information things like that
um
and also potentially more complex
environments for the model so if I have
multiple experiments of data that
someone may have uh if I'm giving models
additional information about about
responses uh sort of whether or not any
of these things change
uh
and that's all I've got for you guys
thanks so much
[Applause]
thanks a lot uh time for one quick
question maybe while the next speaker
sets up
experiment that you did the ah like so
you have the line did you understand
exactly
yeah so what um
the experiment is is uh
essentially this type of setup
oh sorry I apologize the experiment is
going to be more or less this type of
setup for 50 different questions that a
subject is going to see
um so the x-axis corresponds to a bundle
of Aero Securities for State one the
y-axis corresponds to a bundle of error
Securities for state two
and an error security is is an asset
that will pay off one if the state
associated with the error security is
realized in zero otherwise and so I've
got these two states of the world uh one
and two and sort of the x-axis
corresponds to the error security for
this first state and uh the y-axis
corresponds to the Aero security for the
second state and so how I can interpret
any upon this line is that you know if
if I'm at some arbitrary point and if I
select this if State one is realized the
x-axis uh is uh the x coordinate is what
I'm going to be paid and if state two is
realized the y-axis is what I'm going to
be paid and we actually pay subjects the
uh money based on the actual choices
that they make and they do this we do
this 50 times per subject
well thanks a lot